good morning everyone welcome to our
first panel which is called information
policy what it is and why we need it we
have three guest speakers here today
panelists today and they each have their
own perspective and specialization in
the area of information policy I will
introduce them in the order in which
they will speak and then we will have
time for questions our first speaker is
Craig cram he's associate director of
information part of copyright and
information policy at New York Public
Library our second speaker is heather
joseph direktor at spark the scholars
scholarly publishing an academic
resource coalition our third speaker was
scheduled to be barbara jones from the
office of the of intellectual freedom at
the American Library Association she
unfortunately had a last-minute
cancellation and could not make it today
Jim Neil will be here inviting her in
person and delivering remarks on her
behalf was I should say probably less
than 12 hours notice so thank you for
doing that i'm barbara jones and you're
not good morning
everyone so forgive me for the little
I've got a little bit of a cold and
can't hear out of one year so it's gonna
be a little bit of interesting available
we'll see how this goes so first thanks
to Columbia for having me this Jim's
talking Carol's talk we were certainly
inspiring and I certainly have some
threads to pull on it um so first I'm
gonna start off about me and what I do
so I work at this place this beautiful
marble palace down the road a bit I love
working there I'm the Associate Director
of copyright and information policy at
NYPL what does that mean no one knows my
job title means as we try to fix it and
say copyright but still I get questions
what does that mean
well there's 45 of us roughly who do
what I do at libraries and that's a
number that's doubled in the last three
years but of those forty-five there's
only one of us who works at a public
library and that's me I'm the copyright
person at mi piel and I am a copyright
nerd my job at NYPL is first to expand
access as broadly as possible both here
in the physical space but also in the
digital space my job is to work with
curators to increase access to our
collections as broadly as possible and
my second job is don't get sued very
important part of that my third job more
recently has been to engage in copyright
policy conversations both in DC and in
New York especially now that Congress
has started a review of copyright law my
role is to advocate on behalf of NYPL
and its users for better and more
rational copyright policy in fact last
year we testified before Congress on
behalf of NYPL about the first-sale
doctrine Jim actually testified the last
year - on preservation issues of in
libraries so why are libraries creating
these kinds of positions why have our
ranks doubled in the last three years
well it kind of goes back to our usage
so a couple years ago we had 1.6 million
research materials used at NYPL 1.6
million that's a good number it's it's
actually been going up a little bit
but at the same time we had a hundred
and twenty-seven million digital images
viewed on our website
that's an eighty times difference
between the two for a hundred years
we've focused our energy on physical
objects but now we're increasingly
focused on digital access this shifts
this changes Jim discussed in his
presentation from users coming to
libraries to libraries meeting users in
their space has some important
implications the first implication is
that libraries are digitizing their
collections whether in-house or using
partners this small little partner
entered the space in 2004 and now has
over 25 million volumes in its corpus
libraries are starting to push that
digitized content beyond the four
corners of their websites they're
sharing that digital content with third
parties to enhance access and reach
users and using entities like DPLA the
digital Public Library of America and
Hadi trust an important preservation
partner that you've already heard about
a little bit this morning but this
digitization and sharing has its own
implications and first that's copyright
liability right so statutory damages are
up to $150,000 per infringement if we
digitize ten items and hit the maximum
statutory damages that's 1.5 million if
we digitize a thousand items and hit the
maximum statutory damages that's a
hundred and fifty million dollars those
numbers get really big and really scary
really quickly but because the stakes
are so high libraries need to do the
research necessary to understand and
accept the risk of digitizing their
collections and making them more broadly
available unfortunately we we've had a
few copyright lawsuits against libraries
in recent years but the good news is
that libraries have been mostly
successful at defending their activities
last June an appeals court confirmed
that Hadi trusts uses of its scans of
digital books were lawful that's good
news and that's because of a doctrine
called fair use the doctrine of fair use
can play an important role in achieving
the goals of libraries and I think
that's the most important issue facing
libraries in the cop
right it's fear today although the
rights holder has certain rights to
exploit their works those rights are
balanced with the exceptions and
limitations that allow users to use
works in certain ways without the
permission of the rights holder this
balance is based in the constitutional
clause establishing copyright law it
says the Congress shall have the power
to promote the progress of science and
useful arts by securing for limited
times to authors and inventors the
exclusive right to their respective
writings and drawings of all of the
exceptions and limitations found in
copyright law today fair use is by far
the broadest and does the most work it
serves to promote the progress of
knowledge by allowing courts to evaluate
whether new uses should be permitted
without the permission of the rights
holder it's the most frequently and
cited exception in the copyright law and
billions of dollars of businesses of
business are based on the fair use on
fair use for a little review there are
four factors in fair use the first is
asking what the purpose and character of
the use is how are you using that work
are you using it for commercial purposes
and in fact over the last 20 years or so
this factor has shifted a little bit to
include the question of whether your
work is for whether your use is
transformative
did you add value to the original did
you create new information aesthetics
and sights insights or understandings to
the original work if you did that may
tend toward fair use second factor is
the nature of the work was it highly
creative the work that you want to use
was a highly creative was it unpublished
if it's highly factual then there's more
latitude to reuse that item on for I
mean this is kind of a less of an
important factor today it really it's
back to the first factor is more
important than this factor but it's it's
in the fact it's in the list the third
factor is how much did you use was it
the appropriate amount for the purpose
that you were trying to make of the of
the item did you take the most important
bits if you did that's going to tend
against fair use but if you only use a
small portion of it that may tend toward
fair use and finally the fourth factor
is the market impact how did you impact
the market up for the
original work in your uses and if your
work if your use is transformative
then there's likely no market for that
transformative use and and therefore you
may not be impacting the market at all
so those are the four factors in fair
use so now I'm gonna tell you a little
bit a story a story about a collection
that we looked at and use fair use to
make available today so in nineteen in
nineteen nineteen thirty-nine in
nineteen forty sixty Nations 33 States
and US territories and over a thousand
exhibitors gathered in Queens New York
for the World's Fair over forty five
million people visited the fair over the
two seasons at the conclusion of the
fair the corporation the corporation
responsible for the fair donated their
records to NYPL
the donation included more than twenty
five hundred boxes of Records and
documents as well as 12,000 promotional
photographs this collection is heavily
heavily used by researchers so we wanted
to digitize at twelve thousand photos to
make them available online so we
researched the collection to understand
the copyright issues and attempted to
locate a rights holder we spent many
days searching the corporate records
since we had them all and we were unable
to find who currently owns the rights in
the collection in fact we couldn't
figure out how the rights were
transferred at the ending of the
corporations dissolution if we wanted it
to move forward with this collection
without a seeking license we would have
to understand the risk of digitizing
this collection and making it available
online and the risk wasn't something
easily dismissed in the worst case
scenario digitizing all of these photos
we would have been on the hook for 1.8
billion dollars in potential liability
roughly 7 times M IPL's annual budget
for 1200 photo 12,000 photos so knowing
this risk and despite that huge and
scary number we conducted a fair use
analysis of our uses of the uses we
wanted to make and we determined that
despite this huge number the risk was
small that someone would actually object
and let alone someone bring a lawsuit
against us so we accepted that risk in
light of our mission to expand access to
our material and decided to digitize the
collection of photos and here are the
results so we made an interesting a
number of interesting and productive
uses of
the first use was digitizing it and
making me available online in our
digital collections platform we also
created a website that added context of
the collection including memo or
including notes from curators and an
interesting new content that was added
next to the world's fair content finally
we even created an iPad application that
was named one of the top educational
apps for that year
it was all without any take downs we
haven't received takedown requests since
these things have been up and we don't
expect to get one anytime soon Barry's
played a significant role in our
decision to do these things we felt
comfortable that his orphan works there
was likely no market harmed to these
photos for our uses and we felt that our
uses were transformative therefore we
did the project I have some more good
news not every institution has a me
there's only 45 of us in the country but
but because fair use has become such a
critical tool for libraries to achieve
their missions there are more and more
resources available to help libraries
make decisions and although a fair use
determinations are made on a
case-by-case analysis there are some
general principles that tend to favor
fair use there have been a number of
codes of best practices in recent years
that have come out talking about how
fair use can work and the some of the
some of the factors that go towards a
finding of fair use these best practices
are put out by the organization's most
dealing with these complicated issues
including the one in the middle by ARL
there's even an entire week dedicated to
fair use in February if you missed it
it'll be again next year it's the end of
February um there's plenty of
opportunities to learn more about fair
use with a growing desire and capability
to digitize our collections and make
them more broadly available fair use is
the most critical copyright issue for
research libraries today as Jim said
we're changing from being risk adverse
to understanding that risk is necessary
to achieve our missions but not saying
that we should put everything we have
online in full text right now libraries
are not pirates but it is not civil
disobedience to assert that exceed the
exceptions and limitations granted to us
by Congress to assert and use those
exceptions of limitations we should not
be in constant fear of being sued
instead we should
be constantly afraid that not asserting
limitations and exceptions is hurting
our mission just as we keep our doors
open despite the risk that we'll get
sued for a slip and fall
we should similarly be willing to take
reasonable inform risks when we believe
our uses are likely to be fair uses
Carol quoted President Roosevelt and
I'll add one more far better it is to
dare mighty things to win glorious
triumphs even though checkered by
failure then to rank with those timid
spirits who neither enjoy nor suffer
much because they live in the great
Twilight that knows neither victory or
defeat dare mighty things use your fair
use and we can do it so that was the
most masterful use of PowerPoint since
Larry Lessig and I think you're like now
a legend in this community and have set
the bar you'll notice that I don't have
any powerpoints and this is because the
symposium is in Jim Neal's honor and the
first presentation I ever did in front
of Jim 15 years ago he came up to me and
he said great message but you wrote your
speech on your powerpoints and it was
true I think when I first started I used
my powerpoints as my script so it's
staying in honor of you I have a script
but it's not on PowerPoint and it's not
a strict script actually it is more of
trying to use this opportunity to
express a little bit about what Jim has
enabled in the information policy
environment for those of us who work in
and for the library community um Jim was
the chair of the board of spark which is
the organization that he along with many
other esteemed colleagues in Carroll
Mandela and Kenny in the room today
helped have found about 13 or 14 years
ago and he chaired that that
organization when I came aboard as
director nine years ago and it's no
accident that sparks spark was created
with a specific mission and that mission
is specifically to be a catalyst for
action it's the first line of our
mission statement it's how we describe
ourselves it's what we live to try to
achieve every day and sparks mission of
taking action is in a very
specific lair of the world we inhabit in
the library community and that's the
lair of providing equitable access and
ensuring productive use of materials in
the digital environment and so sparks
mission really is to look for ways to
effect positive change to a 10 billion
dollar a year industry that basically
has had a lock on distributing in
specific one layer of information and
that's journal articles as well as
controlling the rules of the game in
terms of how those articles can not only
be accessed and shared but also used and
reused in the digital environment so
sparks way of operating thanks to our
founders has always been to try to sift
through options to try to find pressure
points in this very very large very very
global and complex system to look for
those pressure points that if we push on
might just give a little or if we're
successful give a lot in terms of moving
the markets and the system in a positive
direction and we had lots of possible
power points pressure points power
points
not so Freudian slip there lots of
possible pressure points that we could
think about poking at or or working on
in the environment business models
technologies organizational structures
all very worthy pressure points to
explore but the pressure point that we
have settled on and really worked on for
the last ten years is the the pressure
point of policy and that's because it
really presents a unique opportunity to
do something very large and that's
change the underlying rules of the
playing field or game board that the
system is that the system is operating
on and that that's a big deal I mean
that's a big opportunity and it's
interesting because the the particular
pressure point that we focused on taking
down barriers to access and the
productive reuse of information and
creating a new level and an open playing
field is not an area which was
particularly active in in terms of
specific policies designed to address
this space and increasing access to
research results frankly was not in the
interest of the industry who whose
interests were being served over the
last several decades the closest the
best by the the rules that existed in no
interest in changing the the playing
field yet we in the library community
really and truly did this is an
existential area for us to get right so
one key thing that Jim has taught me is
that we always have choices we have
choices in any given situation on how we
choose to act or react and I think that
that's so important we can be reactive
or proactive we can choose to play
defense or we can choose to play offense
and we chose to play offense in the
policy arena in a new way we really
chose to go all-in and be part of the
process of actively creating and shaping
new policies that would reset the rules
and set new operating terms in this
particular space
would better serve our communities need
and that meant a willingness to be bold
to knock on doors and to ask for a seat
at any table where decisions were being
made that would affect the policies in
this specific arena we are the library
community we generally tend to ask and
not politely and we should do that we
need to do that that's the starting
point but what we've also learned is
that we need to knock politely firmly
insistently repeatedly however long we
need to do it until the door opens the
role of activists as Jim pointed out in
his open opening remarks is thankfully
completely consistent with the role of
librarian and library professional as
long as what we're advocating for once
the door is open and we get the seat at
the table is in advances the mission of
our institutions and professions and it
is really in harmony with the values
that sustain our community as the
library community as the Academy as well
as serve the public and the public's
interest it's that connection that makes
it so important for us to play the role
of advocate in this arena and I was kind
of grateful kind of coming into this new
way of thinking and operating - to look
around the policy environment to see how
our community was acting in other areas
and in particular in the the area of
privacy and protecting our patrons
privacy rights I was really pleased to
see that that was an area where this
community has been really singularly
unafraid and one day I was doing a
Google search for an image to try to
find to illustrate a talk about why we
should why the library community was was
ideally suited to be activists and I
came across a t-shirt that the community
someone in the community had created
around the time some provisions in the
Patriot Act were being challenged and
the t-shirt simply read libraries the
thin blue line between you and the FBI
and and I thought yeah okay we're in the
right space were the right people to be
doing this and and we should be unafraid
playing offense playing defense being
proactive tanked is standing back one
other thing that Jim has taught me is
that those are just stances and that
they both have merits and you need to
use them as stances as strategies
sometimes simultaneously and pick your
spots for what works best in what
situations we we simply have to the only
thing we need to do is is choose which
strategy to deploy and stand up and do
it very simple terrifying
responsibilities an exhilarating
opportunity all wrapped up into one and
that's what we've tried to do in the
terms of in terms of the the policy
arena the policy area of opening up
access to the results of research if
I've learned nothing else from Jim its
before we look at taking action we have
to make sure that we do our homework at
a retirement for one of my colleagues
Jim said something that I'm sure you
don't remember but that has stayed with
me when my predecessor retired Jim
commented that one of the things he
admired about Rick Johnson the founding
executive director of spark was his work
ethic and he used the line there's
simply no substitute for doing the work
and I've taken that to heart
over the last decade because we are most
effective as a library community in
influencing policy when we're considered
expert and when our community's
collective expertise is respected are in
our influence can be leveraged
exponentially when we have that position
of authority and there's no faking
expertise there's no no meaning in empty
rhetoric you have to do the legwork we
have to find the meaningful data to back
up our positions and because we're
libraries we always always always find
the data and we always always always
source it properly and people respect
that and we do the research and what's
more if the research doesn't exist we
find the credible
experts and encourage them to do it and
then we thoughtfully consider the
results we get the facts and we don't
ignore the inconvenient ones when we
shape our position we do shape our
position together we make our plan we
get buy-in from the community and then
and only then do we take action to be
proactive in this policy environment as
library professionals were individuals
as well as part of a larger community
and larger sets of communities on top of
that and our options for sort of seizing
the reins and taking actions in the
policy arena reflect to those operating
realities we have lots of options for
how we can choose to be proactive in
this environment we can take individual
action or collective action and again
what we've learned is that both are
appropriate both need to happen they can
happen simultaneously or they can happen
individually as individuals if you do
take that afternoon a slow afternoon and
read Jim Stevie you'll see that this is
something that he's lived as an
individual as well as a library director
as well as as a member of library
organizations and as well as a leader in
coalitions of groups that span a much
larger reign than the library community
itself we can choose to take individual
action by taking a seat on the study
group or round table or advisory council
when it when it's offered to us and be
prepared to contribute be prepared with
our homework to contribute effectively
we can take action by writing that
letter writing that op-ed going to the
meeting presenting at the briefing give
the testimony at the hearing we can take
action collectively by using the
strengths of a community the library
community speaking with one voice and
standing together for one principle we
can also help define that principle the
principle that the public deserves
access to the results of research that
their public tax dollars fund simply did
not exist before led by Jim the library
community helped to articulate that
principle and make it now part of not
only the law of the US but international
laws that are being developed around the
world
the principle of democratizing access to
knowledge is one that we represent
probably better than any and more
knowledgeably than any community that's
out there and standing together we do we
represent that principle very
effectively one of the things that's
very important is to find the places
proactively where we can take action
when we started out we were very
tentative in terms of finding the right
place and knocking on the right door ten
years ago one bill was a big deal and
one bill is a big deal it's still an
enormous deal but what we found out as
we've progressed is that the policy
playing field in the research arena in
particular is multi-dimensional and
global and we've had to find a way to
play effectively on this
three-dimensional chess board
by working not only with our
institutional politics and policies
state policies and politics national
policy policies and politics but also
international policies and politics and
I think we're seeing the fruits of that
come to fruition as a campaign in a
campaign that we're running right now
which is to educate every single
possible potential presidential 2016 US
presidential candidate on these issues
of the importance of opening up access
to research articles data and
educational resources and finally
something that Jim said near the end of
his talk is something that interestingly
coincidentally I also chose to to
emphasize at the end of my talk which is
it how to say this the right way
we have a wonderful coalition and a
wonderful community it's so important
for us to continue to think about the
ways that we can effectively expand the
communities that we work with Jim was
right to point out that probably one of
our biggest risks is to continue to
identify and empower and effectively
train the advocates who are willing to
play on this crazy multi-dimensional
chessboard in this policy environment
and to do it effectively to really be
equipped to go ahead it sounds great to
say
beyond that Study Committee testify in
front of Congress it's terrifying to
most people when they're actually called
on to do it we need to help empower a
whole new set of people to be able to do
this effectively and the most but to my
mind and one of the things that we're
trying to work on now in the library
community and through our efforts at
spark in particular is to reach out to
our students our early career
researchers and our young librarians and
give them the opportunity to get trained
and get empowered to be that next
effective set of voices in this arena a
program that we ran last year I think
encapsulate the possibilities and the
the optimism that we should feel that
people want to do this we just need to
give them the opportunities to train
them up to do this we ran a conference
in Washington DC and invited students
early career researchers and young
librarians to apply to come and spend
four days in our nation's capital to
work with leaders in the open community
open data open education open access to
learn about issues and to become trained
to speak up as advocates they spent four
days with leaders and their peers and
had one full day of training to take
meetings with a professional we turn
them loose with supervision of course
on members of Congress federal agencies
with their ambassadors and their their
representatives and also with the White
House the thing that I want to point out
the most is that we're repeating this
program again this year we'd like to do
it not just once but we'd like to make
this a regular thing because we were
able to support a hundred and ten of the
2,000 students and early career
researchers and librarians who applied
to be part of this the demand is there
there's reason for optimism Jim is right
to point out that this is an area of
tremendous risk but we see the need cede
the whole and we can collectively step
up to the plate and fill it thank you
before Jamil speaks I would just like to
deliver some words on behalf of Barbara
Jones as I said director of the office
of intellectual freedom at American
Library Association she could not be
here today but she did wish to make an
announcement and this is like the first
announcement of this that Jim Neel had
been awarded the freedom to read
foundation a role on or for 2015 so this
is a this is a statement I am so sorry
that I could not be be here to thank Jim
Neil in person for all he has done for
the American Library Association
Association the freedom to read
Foundation and the International
Federation of Library Association's in
particular he has vigorously supported
the core values of these organizations
when others might have taken a more
expedient route Jim and I have worked
together as far away as Japan for a flaw
and for decades in ala and freedom to
read foundation he claims the record for
the amount of funds he raised for
academic libraries in particular for the
freedom to read foundation and we are
deeply grateful as we celebrate our 45th
year for this constant dedication to
freedom to read Jim has just been
awarded the freedom to read foundation
roll of Honor for 2015
details are forthcoming and he will
accept the award in San Francisco ala
annual meeting in June
you raise a lot of money they got to
give you an award against them so let me
just say one thing that I called out
from my earlier remarks community
standards family values national
security political correctness too often
become excuses for censorship and
rationales to violate our privacy
progress in technology too often becomes
an excuse to purge information block
access monitor behavior and lost an
advance one point of view that is why I
have made a career commitment as it
being very much part of the freedom to
read advocacy it's an illness I'm
serving my third term on the Executive
Board of the American Library
Association but that gives me an
opportunity to work with the office of
intellectual freedom I'm in the middle
of my fourth term on the board of the
freedom to read foundation so I've been
on the educational side oh I F and on
the advocacy and legal side of this
extraordinary set of issues to me
there's nothing more important to our
professional values than what we do
through the work of oh I F and the
freedom to read foundation let me read
barber statement I'm so sorry I can't be
with you today due to illness thanks to
Jim for delivering my remarks in my role
on committee a of the American
Association of University Professors and
in my own career as an academic
librarian for 35 years I have seen the
freedom to read in action and what
happens when it is threatened on Bascom
Hill at the University of
wisconsin-madison there is a plaque from
a tenure case in 1894 which was decided
by the UW Board of Regents in favor of
tenure this is what it says whatever may
be the limitations with trowel inquiry
elsewhere we believe that the great
State University of Wisconsin should
ever encourage that continual and
fearless sifting and winnowing by which
alone the truth can be found I'm sending
this to the governor of Wisconsin I that
was a parenthetical statement academic
libraries are where students faculty and
staff and the community do that
essential sifting and winnowing the
library has content via cuneiform
tablets medieval manuscripts of Toni
Morrison novel digital journals or 3d
printing of a human heart some day soon
how do we put intellectual freedom in
action so that faculty and students get
the benefits of the treasure of
information in all its diversity this
content must be made available with as
few barriers as possible one of the most
insidious barriers is the software
filter yes some academic libraries do
have filters these prevents scholars
researchers and students from sifting
and winnowing among various websites and
data if some points of view are blocked
from consideration people may miss the
information they need it is crucial that
students learn how to evaluate
information sources and they can't if
bad examples are filtered out a
frequently overlooked barrier is reader
privacy it was at Columbia University
that one of Columbia's librarians Paula
Kaufman recently retired library
director from University of Illinois
urbana-champaign stood up in the 1980s
against the FBI's monitoring of
international students the FBI asked her
to provide the names of foreign library
student patrons or students with accents
and to reveal what databases they
searched she refused what she made this
library when she made this library
awareness program public it rocked the
library community in LA to Al aids one
of its proudest moments in fighting this
invasion
the privacy of our students at one
University where I worked faculty did
not want books on creationism in the
library only titles on Darwin's
evolutionary theory how then do students
know what Darwin's support opponents are
talking about even if it flies in the
face of scientific method right up the
street from here the Jewish Theological
Seminary holds copies of the protocols
of the Elders of Zion which is in some
parts of the world considered as true
but in fact was published as a
propaganda tool jts wants its students
to understand what anti-semitism in the
earliest 20th century Russia looked like
academic libraries are increasingly the
home for civic engagement and activities
supporting critical thinking after the
Sandy Hook massacre holy cross this
library held a community discussion
about gun violence libraries are the
perfect place for people to interact
with information and with each other and
to have information at their
fingerprints should they want to explore
further students must be informed about
intellectual freedom and privacy in
order to exercise their right to read
and to protest when it is taken away
when the office for intellectual freedom
sponsored to university student interns
to help us bring banned book weeks to
college campuses they were shocked that
censorship exists in the Academy and the
students at Lane tech college prep high
school learned the hard way when the
College Chicago Public Schools attempted
to remove the novel the graphic novel
persopolis from the curriculum the
students staged a 700 sit down 700
student sit down in the halls they made
the national use in the Chicago Public
Schools eventually restored the book to
the curriculum campuses must resist the
temptation to buckle to donors and
wealthy parents who are prospective
donors at one of my positions I was
asked not to purchase LGBT materials
from a particular donor funded this
problem is increasing as donors fund
campus
buildings and programs with more strings
attached and administrators need more
funds for campus survival finally the
latest threat to linked intellectual
freedom is from trigger warnings the
AAUP Committee on a and academic freedom
recently released a statement about the
labeling of course materials that may
trigger PTSD or other responses from
students my favorite example is the
Chinua Achebe book Things Fall Apart
recommended for a trigger warning at one
campus because it might cause a violent
response to those oppressed by
colonialism the AAU Committee statement
warns that libraries could be pressured
to label books that might lead to trauma
it hasn't happened yet to my knowledge
but it is possible as librarians devoted
to information literacy to critical
thinking and assisting and winnowing how
can we best uphold our core values the
freedom to read foundation the ACR ELLs
Committee on professional values the
office for intellectual freedom are well
established professionally expert places
to get started people working in
libraries must learn those cores about
core values whether they are a library
guard or whether they are the library
director and one of my jobs the guards
were pulling students away from computer
terminals when they reviewing content
that offended the guards it only took
one conversation with the guards to
change that situation sadly oh I F
survey of lis programs does not show a
deep commitment to teaching core values
even if this a commitment appears in our
library school accreditation standards
I am constantly shocked by a facebook
conversation among new librarians and
how much they were not taught in library
school about what was labeled as porn
the freedom to refoundation has
established a graduate level credit
bearing course at the University of
Illinois and we provide scholarships in
text books for students around the world
this I think this is barbar statement I
think there are there has been a
historical tendency to look at issues of
access
to information freedom to read issues as
public library issues because of the
notoriety of the attempts in schools and
in public settings to ban books but I
think there are many things going on in
the academic environment which we need
to be concerned about and to make sure
that our students and faculty are in no
way compromised in their ability to
access and use the information that they
need there are enormous risks so I
encourage everyone in this room if you
are not a member of the freedom to read
foundation it is only $35 per year and
I'll get you signed up if you want from
the audience I would perhaps like to
begin with a question to Heather if you
can perhaps address what concerns SPARC
may have with the 2016 election coming
up and how that may affect the open
access specifically the 2013 memorandum
so this so the specific concern okay
specific concern that we have is that
the memorandum is just that a memorandum
that doesn't actually carry the weight
of law and a new administration can
overturn it with basically the stroke of
a pen so the election is important to us
to to make sure we have an
administration that comes in that holds
the value of open access and reusability
of research assuming that Congress
doesn't codify it into the permanent law
okay Craig I was also wondering you got
me at expand access certainly that's
something that we all promote but then
you talked about not getting sued and
most libraries are not like fortunate
enough to have someone like you on board
if they have legal counsel it's usually
the same person who does real estate and
HR and the advice that librarians
usually get is don't do so how do you
balance that chilling effect with what
our mission is within institutions where
digitization is happening so I'll give
our General Counsel's credit and not
just say they're always saying no it
took us four years but we got there we
we had long conversations with our
general counsel about
our mission and how saying no every time
impacts our ability to do our work
those best practices statements that you
saw we're a helpful way to start those
conversations we were able to say this
is what the community of practice
believes is a fair use this is what we
think is going to be within the bounds
of fair use and it's time to get on
board
it was also helpful to have senior
management who were very invested in
that to say you know we're willing to
take that risk on we understand the
legal risk but we're willing to take it
on okay I guess everybody needs their
coffee by now so thank you for your
participation